Guten Tag, mein Name ist Demir. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt und möchte Ihnen das Aufnahmgespräch führen.
Aber bevor ich damit beginne, bitte ich um Ihre persönliche Information. Sind Sie damit anverstanden?
Ja, möchten Sie Wasser trinken? Ich trinke immer viel Wasser.
Danke. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich habe viel gewartet hier. Mein Name ist Henrika Maia. Wie kommt es, dass man so lange warten muss, Herr Demir?
Frau Maia, es tut mir leid, dass Sie so lange gewartet haben. Aber heute ist viel los. Jetzt sind Sie dran. Ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Danke. Können Sie bitte um Ihre Vor- und Nachname küsstabeln?
Wie heißt mein Name?
Henrika Maia.
Okay.
E, N, R, I, K, A.
A.
Maia, M, E, Y, E.
Können Sie bitte zweite Buchstabe Ihres Nachnamens wiederholen bitte? E wie Eger oder E wie Essen?
Die beiden E wie Essen.
E wie Essen. Okay.
Herr Maia, wie alt sind Sie?
Frau, Frau. Henrika.
Frau, Henrika. Wie alt sind Sie?
Drei und sechzig.
Wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
Neunzehnhundertdreiundsechzig.
Und Tag und Monat können Sie sagen?
Okay. Vierundzwanzigstenzwölften.
Vierundzwanzigstenzwölften.
Und Sie sind zweiundsechzig Jahre alt.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ein Meter siebenundachtzig.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Neunundachtzigkommatachtkilo.
Frau Maia, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Heute sind wir mit meinem Mann am rein Spazieren.
Da fühle ich mich nicht gut.
Ein bisschen schwindelig.
Deswegen will ich hierher kommen.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung hierher zu kommen.
Ich habe auch Kopfschmerzen.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ungefähr seit drei Tagen fühle ich mich nicht gut.
Aber heute vielleicht frische Luft wäre besser, habe ich gedacht.
Aber nein, schaffe ich nicht.
Sie hatten schon einmal eine ähnliche Beschwerde?
Ja, früher habe ich immer wieder Kopfschmerzen.
Und während Kopfschmerzen fühle ich mich schwindelig.
Ja, ungefähr vielleicht ein Jahr.
Zunächst können wir über Schwindel sprechen.
Könnten Sie die Schwindel beschreiben?
Dreht sich er wie in einem Kause?
Die zweite Schwindel.
Und besonders ein Unsicherheitsgefühl habe ich.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Und haben Sie schon einmal Schwindelattacke gehabt?
Oder das hat erstmals aufgetreten?
Wie habe ich gesagt, seit drei Tagen, besonders wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe,
fühle ich mich schwindelig und brauche ein paar Sitze.
Und ich schwitze mehr als sonst.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Und manchmal habe ich auch Herzklopfen.
Seit wann? Seit drei Tagen oder mehr?
Seit drei Tagen.
Und könnten Sie die Kopfschmerzen beschreiben?
Sind sie eher dumpf, drückend, brennend oder ziehend?
Klopfend und pulsierend, kann ich sagen.
Aber die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Abends weniger, aber abends nach der Arbeit,
mein Kopf verrückt wegen Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen, 10 am starken Schmerzen bedeutet.
Morgen kann ich 6 sagen, und abends würde ich 8 sagen.
Das tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Brauchen Sie die Medikamente, oder könnten Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Moment brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe Ibuprofen, 600 mg.
Ich habe ihn angenommen.
Gott sei Dank ist das mein Manns Medikament.
Er hat Hexenschuss.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Das ist eine Gorken-Schmerzen.
Ja.
Er hat mir seine Medikamente geholft.
Er hat ihn gefolgt.
Er gibt mir und Ibuprofen hilft auch mir.
Gott sei Dank.
Alles klar.
Gab es Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin stressig bei der Arbeit.
Ich bin beckern und immer morgens fragen,
ich kann es nicht aushalten.
Können Sie bitte, meine Bitte ist das,
ich würde gerne krankgeschrieben,
für Rente kommen.
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Ich kann nicht weiter machen.
Können Sie bitte für dieses Thema helfen?
Ich würde gerne mit Ihren Oberarzt sprechen.
Darf ich?
Frau Meier, leider sind wir in der Notaufnahme.
Deswegen kann ich Ihnen über dieses Thema nicht helfen.
Aber für diese Frührente
sollen Sie Ihren Hausarzt besuchen.
Dann muss er den Antrag
im Rentenversicherung unterstützen.
Aber leider kann ich es nicht machen.
Das tut mir leid.
Ich bin nicht gut mit meinem Hausarzt.
Aber wenn Sie einen neuen Hausarzt brauchen,
kann ich Ihnen helfen.
Kann sein, man kann Hausarzt wechseln.
Natürlich können Sie das machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wenn Sie Unterstützung brauchen, stehen wir Ihnen zur Seite.
Okay, danke.
Aber vielleicht können Sie auch
von Ihrem Oberarzt meine Wünsche bitten.
Ja, ich bespreche Oberarzt.
Okay, ja. Ich kann warten.
Ja, jetzt machen wir das Aufnahmengespräch weiter.
Okay.
Ist es etwas, das die Kopfschmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ibuprofen, ein bisschen gehäuft.
Außer Ibuprofen? Stehen, Bewegung oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt. Nein.
Okay, strallen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Keine Strahlung, aber immer hier.
Die beiden Seiten schlafen seit.
Haben die Schmerzen plötzlich oder allmählich aufgetreten?
Ganz langsam.
Langsam? Alles klar.
Und lassen Sie uns über Schwinde sprechen?
Und haben Sie Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein.
Aber als würde ich schwarze Flecken vor meinen Augen sehen.
Und hatten Sie Unfall? Haben Sie sich den Kopf verletzt?
Nein.
Und haben Sie andere Beschwerden neben Kopfschmerzen und Schwindeln?
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit zum Beispiel?
Mir ist Übel, ja. Sie haben Recht.
Deswegen, aber ich kann nicht mehr essen, aber nicht auch wenig kann ich sagen.
Ich habe salziges Essen. Ich wähle salziges Essen.
Das ist gut gegenüber Übel.
Und ich trinke im Moment viel Wasser.
Weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht drei Liter am Tag.
Ich habe mir immer Durst.
Eigentlich ist drei Liter nicht viel.
Gut.
Haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nein.
Sie haben nur Übelkeit.
Und ich bin sehr gestresst bei der Arbeit.
Was machen Sie für einen Beruf?
Bäckere.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Bäckere sind.
Das ist echt schwer für mich.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Seite Erbrochen zugenommen?
Seit drei Jahren habe ich 5 Kilo zunehmen.
Zunehmen seit vier Jahren?
Zugenommen, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber? Fühlen Sie sich pfiffig?
Nein. Vielleicht wegen meiner Pause.
Manchmal fühle ich mich wärm, aber...
Seit wann sind Sie in der Wechseljahre?
Seit 15 Jahren.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja. Ich mag meinen Frauenarzt.
Vor sechs Monaten war ich da.
Frau Meier, leiden Sie an einer chronischen Erkrankung?
Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich seit fünf Jahren Bluthochdruck habe.
Aber die ersten zwei Jahre möchte ich die Medikamente nicht nutzen.
Nicht einnehmen.
Aber seit drei Jahren nehme ich meine Medikamente regelmäßig.
RamiPril 5 Milligramm.
Wann war Ihr letzter Blutdruck?
Nein, nein. Wann war Ihr letzter Blutdruck?
Weiß ich nicht.
Sie haben sich nicht erinnert.
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Wie häufig messen Sie Ihren Blutdruck?
Einmal pro Woche oder...
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Wo soll ich messen? Aber ich nehme meine Medikamente regelmäßig.
Okay, das verstehe ich. Aber Sie sollten Ihren Blutdruck regelmäßig messen.
Ja, wie habe ich gesagt? Ich bin nicht gut mit meinen Hausarztinnen.
Deswegen kann ich ihn nicht besuchen.
Wie kann ich messen?
Heike Meier, nach der Untersuchung passen wir einen neuen Hausarzt.
Aber ich empfehle Ihnen, Ihren Blutdruck regelmäßig zu messen. Das ist sehr wichtig.
Man kann selbst messen?
Ja, natürlich. Sie können es machen.
Wie kann ich das machen?
Sie können mit Blutdruckmessgerät richtig messen.
Haben Sie Blutdruckmessgerät?
Nein, wie kann ich kaufen?
Mit Apotheke. Beim Apotheke können Sie kaufen.
Aber zunächst müssen Sie einen Termin vereinbaren beim Hausarzt.
Okay, machen wir.
Leiden Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Sonst nicht.
Nehmen Sie eine Medikamente außer Ramipril?
Nein, manchmal mein Manns Medikament, Ipoprofen 600.
Ich habe die Schnauze. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Operation... Was kann ich sagen? Ich hatte Gelenblasenprobleme.
Vor 17 Jahren habe ich bei mir eine Operation durchgeführt.
Das war alles in Ordnung.
Alles klar. Frau Meier, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein.
Rauchen Sie?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Zwei Gläser Prosecco oder Wein. Jede zwei Wochen gelegentlich beim Feiern.
Alles klar. Und konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Frau Meier, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater ist wegen Lungenkrankheit gestorben. Aber er hat eine Staublung.
Das tut mir leid zum Verlust Ihres Vaters.
Und wie alt ist er, als er verstorben ist?
Er war 40.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist jetzt 83 Jahre alt. Sie hat ein Kniegelenk, Art Rose.
Und ich habe vier Geschwister.
Drei Schwestern vor drei Schwestern leiden vor einem Jahr an Herzanfall mit 65 Jahren gestorben.
Ja, das tut mir leid.
Danke.
Mein Herz ist beilägt, Frau Meier. Und Sie verraten?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich komme mit meinem Mann hierher.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter. Sie ist ganz gesund.
Okay. Ja, Frau Meier, ich glaube, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt und ich habe alle relevanten Informationen gesammelt.
Nach dem Angabe denke ich, dass es eine Blutdruckung ist.
Aber das ist nur ein Verdacht und muss durch weitere Untersuchungen bestätigt werden.
Zunächst würde ich Ihre körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann würde ich Ihren Blutdruck, insbesondere Ihren Blutdruck, aber auch Blutzucker, Puls,
Fieber messen. Dann würde ich etwas Blut abnehmen.
Dann können wir genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Entschuldigung, ich habe in der Nacht auch dreimal die Toilette gehalten, für Wasserlassen.
Könnten Sie bitte meine Urin überprüfen?
Ja, natürlich. Soll ich.
Okay, das freut mich. Danke. Soll ich hier bleiben?
Für weitere Untersuchungen bleiben Sie im Wartezimmer.
Okay, ich warte auf Ihnen. Danke.
Ich habe eine Reaktion erwartet. Ich habe gesagt, dass ich meine Frau-Inhalte nehme.
Das ist eine Reaktion wie eine Art-Syndesia-Rat.
Diese Patientin hat etwas mit ihren Reaktionen zu tun.
Aber du hast sie nur einmal gesagt, dass sie in die Erdbeere gehen.
Ja, ich habe sie nur einmal gesagt.
Sie hat sie nur einmal gesagt.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du sie mir so gesagt hast.
Und du hast auch gesagt, dass du sie mir über Art-Syndesia geben würdest.
Das ist nicht so. Du weißt nicht, was ich tun kann.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich tun kann.
Dann kannst du sie Berlin senden. Aber du hast ihre Reaktionen gut gemacht.
Du hast sie sehr gut gemacht.
Sie hat sich sehr gut verstanden.
Du hast mich zufrieden.
Wenn du die Anxie der Patientin nimmst, wird sie dir sagen, dass sie dir die Reaktion geben wird.
Ich habe eine Reaktion auf die Angelegenheit.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich keine Angelegenheit habe.
Das wird eine Angelegenheit.
Wenn du das so machen kannst, dann kann ich das nicht machen.
Was bedeutet Angelegenheit?
Angelegenheit bedeutet auch, dass du dich nicht mehr verhüllen kannst.
Ich habe es gesagt, dass du nicht mehr verhüllen kannst.
Nicht mehr verhüllen? Okay.
Danke, dass ich von dir neue Dinge erinnere.
Nicht mehr verhüllen.
Angelegenheit. Okay.
Dieser Patient kann auch mit dem Schäfer kommen.
Er kann sagen, dass er in der Chronik Erkrankung Schäferin hat.
Er kann auch Schütteln beitragen.
Das ist ein Patient.
Die Reaktionen sind gut.
Das ist ein Schäferpatient.
Er ist nicht ein Schäferpatient.
Das kann auch mit dem Schäferpatient kommen.
Du weißt, dass es drei Fakten gibt.
Aber ich habe es nicht gesagt, dass ich Schäferpatient bin.
Ich werde jetzt etwas fragen.
Er kann sagen, dass er Schäferpatient ist und dass er unter Kontrolle ist.
Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen.
Ich werde etwas fragen.
Wie soll ich das einem Patient sagen?
Ich habe das nicht gehört.
Ich habe es bei euch vorhin bemerkt.
Wie soll ich das einem Patienten sagen?
Warum?
Was denke ich über einen Schäferpatient?
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es eine Tension ist.
Aber ich habe nichts anderes in meinem Kopf.
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen.
Ich habe es bei euch vorhin bemerkt.
Du hast es richtig gesagt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es eine Tension ist.
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Bei diesem Patienten muss ich nichts sagen.
Wie lange wird er es machen?
Ich habe es vorhin bemerkt.
Die Tension in der heutigen Fälle ist normal.
Sie hat es vor drei Tagen getroffen.
Sie hat 80 Prozent.
Sie hat die Tension in der Nase gesetzt.
Aber die Tension bei Burnout ist leider anders.
Du hast es nicht mit dem Patienten gesagt.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Das ist bei Burnout.
Wenn ich die Noten in meiner Hand sehe,
habe ich nicht mit dem Patienten gesprochen,
weil ich heute die hypertensive Entgleisung machen wollte.
Ich habe dich nicht mit den Tenden aus der Erfahrung gemerkt.
Aber ich habe in diesem Protokoll einen falschen Ort gemacht.
Hast du einen Miemann gemacht?
Nein, wir haben eine 149-Leiste.
Ich habe nichts davon.
Ich schaue in die Erfahrungen.
In den Erfahrungen gibt es Piafawka und Rauchabain.
Rauch ist so gesagt.
Rauchabain.
Okay.
In Deutschland gibt es auch Piafawka.
Rauchabain.
In der Chronik-Projecte gibt es Rauchathesis.
Rauchaus.
Wir können diese Reaktionen in der Chronik-Projecte lesen.
Ich habe viele Probleme, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich möchte früher rennten bekommen.
Ich habe eine Behandlung.
Ich kann es nicht verbreiten.
Ich verbreite es normalerweise.
Das ist meine einzige Reaktion.
Sie sagen, sie wollen mich früher rennten.
Sie sagen es zumindest 3-mal.
Vielleicht 7-mal.
Sie sagen es nur 3-mal.
Sie sind nicht zu unserer Sicht.
Ich kann es nicht.
Vielleicht werde ich es später auch noch sagen.
Aber es ist unsere Entscheidung,
eure Wünsche zu finden.
Wir können es nicht ausdrücken.
Denn das ist ein Burn-out.
Das ist die Runde.
Das ist nicht anders als Chronik-Fatigue-Syndrom.
Das ist anders.
Die Frau arbeitet 13 Stunden.
Sie kommt nach Hause.
Sie ist ein Junge.
Sie arbeitet nicht.
Sie ist abends bei der Familie.
Sie schaut auf ihr Geld.
Sie hat Kinder.
Sie macht sie Essen.
Die Frau ist fertig.
Das ist ein Burn-out.
Ich würde mich verabschieden.
Als wir den Mann aus dem Test hatten,
kam er vor.
Er war immer okay.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine Parizoke.
Er hat es im Überrasch gesagt.
Was bedeutet das?
Das ist ein Tempel.
Danke.
Tempel ist ein Kölner.
Wenn er dir kommt ...
Das ist ein Zolder-Dokument nach Berlin.
Warum ist Berlin da?
Weil Rente-Fezi-Scherup in Berlin ist.
Wenn es haust, wird Berlin verabschiedet.
Auch ein Doktor in unserer Klinik kann das verabschieden.
Ich bin in der Aktion.
Ich bin nicht im Interesse.
Ich bin ein Arzt.
Du musst dich dafür übernehmen.
Ich mpt eine Lösung für deine Reaktionen.
Darauf habe ich dich enttäuscht.
Dann machen wir das, Ibrahim.
iquement, dass wir das hier aufregeln.
Man muss das hier aufregeln.
Reaktionen, wie der Patient kommen kann.
Aber so nix, mühreicht diese Frage nicht.
Die gibt es ja immer.
Der andere fragt...
Schau mal, ich werde etwas schreiben.
Ich werde die Fragen schreiben.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine weitere Frage.
Ja.
Fikabla, können wir das Laboratorium vorbereiten?
Ich habe es vorbereitet, Herr.
Kling, kling.
Wollen wir beginnen?
Herr, ich sage erst das Laboratorium.
Nein, ich habe es vorbereitet.
Ich sage es nur, dass wir in den 20 Minuten ein zweites Teil des Testes haben.
Vielleicht ist es anders als das vierte Teil.
In diesen 20 Minuten hast du auch ein bisschen Zeit für ein Teil 3.
Der Teil 3 in den Testen wird ein bisschen besser als der letzte Teil.
Wir sind auch so.
Sie haben die Ars Brif.
Ja, ich habe es nicht in den 20 Minuten vorbereitet.
Wir sind in der gleichen Situation.
Wir müssen spontan vorbereitet werden.
Nur nach dem Anamnes-Kommissionen.
Wir haben ein, zwei Minuten Zeit.
Aber da wir den Ars Brif schreiben,
haben wir uns beide überlegt und uns zusammengehalten.
Das heißt, dass wir das machen.
Wir haben das auch.
Okay.
Ja, hier spricht Demir.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Frau Bergheim.
Kaliumwert 2,58 Millimol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Wert eher überarzt?
Weiter weiter.
2?
2,58.
Kaliumwert.
Ja, Kalium mit Natrium.
Ich teile mit.
Frau Bergheim.
Bergheim schreibt sich?
Ja, ich habe mitge-
Mit Kalium?
Okay.
Schönen Tag. Tschüss.
Hallo, guten Tag, mein Kollege.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ja, möchtest du?
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Was machen Sie heute?
Ja, Herr Doktor,
ich habe eine neue in der Notraufnahme aufgenommen.
Und ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, gerne.
Aber bevor ich damit beginne, bitte ich-
Bevor ich damit beginne, möchte ich Ihnen vor einem wichtigen Labor Anruf berichten.
Eine Kollegin aus dem Labor gerade hat mir telefonisch mitgeteilt,
dass der Kaliumwert von Frau Bergheim bei 2,56 Millimol pro Liter liegt.
Das ist ein anderer Patient?
Ja, ein anderer Patient.
Aber das ist Notfall.
Das kann gefallen.
Okay, können Sie bitte das Wert wiederholen?
2,56 Millimol pro Liter.
Okay, okay.
Und was ist die Normalwerte?
Die Normalwerte liegt bei 3,6 bis 5,2.
3,6? Aber das ist knapp.
Oder?
2,6 Normalwerte, aber-
2,6 nicht normal. 3,6 normal.
Ah, okay. Ich habe 2,6 Perfekt.
Nein, nein, 3,6.
Okay, okay. Das ist niedrig.
Das ist sehr stark niedrig.
Okay, welche Symptome könnte dieser Patient oder diese Patienten haben?
Oder haben Sie eine Vermutung, mit welchen Symptomen können die Patienten kommen?
Ja, eine so ausgeprägte Hypokalämie kann zu Müdigkeit, Muskelschmerzen, Muskelkrämpfe,
in schlimmsten Fall kann man vielmehr sogar Asystolie führen.
Deswegen ist sie lebensbedrohlich.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Das ist lebensbedrohlich.
Ja.
Und könnten Sie bitte die Symptome wiederholen? Welche Symptome erwarten Sie?
Muskelschmerzen, Muskelkrämpfe, in schlimmsten Fall Kama-Flima, Asystolie.
Asystolie, das ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Oligo-Rheum.
Und was noch? Gibt es eine Veränderung bei EKG?
Ja, das kann es erstrecken und neu aufgetretene Uwelle.
Und wie ist der Fall?
T-Welle ist gelöschtes T-Welle. Abnahme der T-Welle.
Welche Ursachen könnten Sie sein oder welche Ursachen erwarten Sie für diesen Fall, für diese Werte?
Ja, am häufigsten Ursache ist Diuretika.
Die als Schleifendiuretika, also Lateinisch-Lukdiuretika.
Und unzureichender Kaliumzufuhr ist andere Ursache.
Und Konzentrum oder Diabetes Incipitus.
Was noch? Diary könnte es sein?
Neureninsuffizienz, Alkaloase.
Diary oder Erbrechen?
Natürlich Wasserverlust. Diary, Erbrechen, Schwitzen ist auch erkennbare Ursache.
Ok, was sollte man behandeln oder wie sollte man behandeln? Was sollen wir tun bei diesem Fall?
Haben Sie Empfehlungen?
Ja, die Therapie richtet sich nach der Ursache.
Wenn Kalium sich höher als 3 befindet, können wir Kalium geben.
Kaliumreiche Ernährung geben, wie zum Beispiel Banane oder Obst.
Aber dieser Wert ist sehr stark erlittig.
Wir sollten Intravenous Kalium geben und im EKG überwachen.
Die Patienten intensiv stationär aufnehmen und ständig überwachen.
Ok, vielen Dank für diese Informationen.
Haben Sie noch weitere Patienten heute?
Ja, meine Patienten. Es handelt sich um Henrike Meyer, ein 62-jähriger Patientin.
Geboren am 20.12.1963.
Sie ist 1,67 Meter groß und wiegt aktuell 89,8 Kilo.
Sie stellt sich seit 3 Tagen bestehenden, progradienten, schwankartigen Vertigo-Attacke.
Das hat erstmals aufgetreten.
Außerdem hat sie angegeben, dass sie Sefage haben.
3 Tage bestehenden, langsam einsetzenden Sefage.
Sie beschreibt Schmerzen als klopfend und pulsierend.
Sie stützt Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala 6 mit 6 von 10 ein.
Als Auslöser für die Schmerzen wurde verneint.
Sie hat über Prophen 600 mg eingenommen, aber sie hatte keine Rezept.
Diese Medikamente gehören zu ihrem Mann.
Außerdem hat sie berichtet, dass sie keine Synkope hat.
Sie hatte keinen Unfall, sie hatte keine Verletzung.
Herr Kollege, der Patient hat seit 3 Tagen Vertigo, Sefage, Palpitation.
Herzpalpitation.
Wir haben diese Beschwerden angefangen plötzlich oder langsam.
Langsam einsetzen.
Seit 3 Tagen sind alle Beschwerden da, oder?
Ja, die Beschwerden sind immer da, aber heute ist sie spazieren gegangen am Rhein.
Und die Beschwerden sind schlimmer geworden.
Schlimmer geworden? Okay, aber seit 3 Tagen. Das ist sehr wichtig, ich glaube.
Seit 3 Tagen, ja. Und was könnte es sein? Seit 3 Tagen hat es im Bezirk viel Schmerzen.
Und mit Vertigo und mit Takukardi.
Sie hat ein arteriales Hyperton, aber sie hat einen Blutdruck nicht.
Seit 3 Tagen hat der Patient andere Beschwerden wie Brustschmerzen oder Nocturie.
Keine Atemnot, sie hat Nocturie, übel Nausea.
Gehimboletung könnte es auch sein seit 3 Tagen.
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie unterbrochen?
Während der Untersuchung frage ich, neurologische Untersuchung frage ich.
Okay, haben Sie dieses Gespräch unterbrochen? Oder was haben Sie gemacht?
Nein, ich habe nicht unterbrochen oder unterbrochen.
Okay, braucht man oder sollten wir unterbrechen?
Was denken Sie? Ja, ich möchte wissen, wo der Kopfschmerzen ist.
Während der Untersuchung frage ich.
Okay, ich glaube das ist wichtig. Wo sind Kopfschmerzen?
Hat der Patient Fieber oder naken Steifigkeit?
Nein, oder?
Während der Untersuchung frage ich.
Okay, weitere Untersuchung bitte, Herr Kollege.
Diese Informationen könnten wichtig sein.
Und Brustschmerzen oder Atemnotdispäne hat der Patient solche Beschwerden?
Sie hat es nicht.
Okay, Sie haben berichtet, dass der Patient Nukturi hat.
Wie viele Mal in der Nacht? Oder hat der Patient auch andere Beschwerden?
Wie Durst haben?
Ja, sie hat Durst. Deswegen trinkt sie mindestens 30-40 Liter.
Okay, 3 Liter täglich.
Meint der Patient, ob es eine Veränderung gibt?
3 Liter, ja es könnte natürlich normal sein, aber gibt es eine Veränderung in nächster Zeit?
Ja, Sie können es auch bei der Untersuchung lernen.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben eine Frage.
Sie können es auch bei der Untersuchung lernen.
Herr Kollege, was noch gibt es noch weitere Beschwerden oder Angaben?
Die Wege der Tifanamnese sind Nausea, Inapathens, Gewichtszunahme.
Gewichtszunahme innerhalb von 3 Jahren von 5 kg auffällig.
Zunahme?
Ja, Zunahme, richtig.
Sie leidet an Arterial Hypertonin seit 15 Jahren. Dagegen nimmt sie Ramipril 5 mg ein.
Seit wann hat der Patient Arterial Hypertonin?
Seit 15 Jahren.
15 oder 5?
Ich glaube 15.
Okay, wir können weiter machen.
Und dagegen nimmt sie Ramipril 5 mg ein.
Hat der Patient immer ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, sie nimmt Medikamenten regelmäßig ein, aber sie misst ihre Blutdruck nicht.
Okay, ja laut ihrer Angaben hat der Patient 5, seit 5 Jahren Arterial Hypertonin und seit 5 Jahren nimmt er ihre Patienten...
Ja, seit 5 Jahren Blutdruck.
Okay, und seit 5 Jahren nimmt der Patient immer regelmäßig Medikament ein?
Ja, richtig.
Okay, weiter bitte. Und welches Medikament?
Ramipril.
Okay, gibt es auch keine Veränderung?
Für Medikament?
Ich glaube keine Veränderung. Sie nimmt immer Ramipril ein.
Okay, weiter bitte.
Sie wurde vor 17 Jahren mit Cholesthektomie operiert. Sie sind nicht allergisch, sie raucht nicht. Sie trinkt 2 Gläser pro Seko jede 2 Wochen.
Sie konsumiert schon einmal keine Drogen.
Ihr Vater ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben. Ihre Mutter leidet an Arthrose.
Sie ist verheiratet und eine gesunde Tochter. Sie ist Bäckerin.
Oder sie arbeitet in der Bäckerin. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie Bäckerin ist oder es eine andere Tätigkeit ist.
Okay, in einer Bäckerei oder bei einer Bäckerei arbeitet sie.
Was ist Ihre Verdachteagnose, Herr Kollege?
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten auf eine hypertensive Entgleisung hin, weil sie vertigo Kopfschmerzen übernausee hat und sie leidet an Bluthochdruck und Arteriellhypertonie.
Allerdings hat sie bisher nicht gemessen, ihr Bluthoch nicht gemessen.
Es wird empfohlen, mindestens einmal pro Woche eine Messung.
Und die veranschiedeten Diagnosen kommen auf Burnout-Syndrom, Anämie und TIA in Betracht.
Seit 3 Tagen TIA. Okay.
Und Burnout-Syndrom, haben Sie gesagt, hat die Patienten Konzentrationsstörung?
Ich glaube ja. Sie hat verminderte Leistung, Leistungsfähigkeit und sie haben Müdigkeit. Aufgrund von Stress bei der Arbeit.
Aber Burnout-Syndrom, ich denke seit langem können die Patienten solche Beschwerden haben.
Der Patient hat nur seit 3 Tagen ein paar Beschwerden. Früher hatte die Patienten keine Beschwerden.
Ja, richtig. Aber das ist eine geringe Möglichkeit.
Ja, das ist eine Differenzial-Diagnose. Sie haben Recht. Und Ihre Verdachteagnose ist hypertensive Entgleisung.
Was meinen Sie? Welche Typen gibt es als hypertensive Entgleisung?
Ja, es gibt zwei Teile hypertansive Entgleisung.
Ich meine, Ihre Blutdruck kann viel zu viel erhöht sein.
Zum Beispiel Erhöhung.
Ja, die Blutdruck ist zwischen 220 bis 280 mm.
Aber bei dieser Situation, was erwarten Sie? Wie hoch erwarten Sie?
Höher als 160 mm.
Oder 60 oder 80, 180, 180, 180, 180, 120.
Welche Typen gibt es als hypertansive Krise oder als hypertansive Notfall?
Was gibt es als hypertansive Krise?
Bei der hypertansiven Notfall gibt es Organ-Schädigung.
Welche Organ-Schädigung erwarten Sie?
Gehirn, Nieren, Leber.
Was noch?
Gehirn, Nieren, Leber, Gastrointestinalverdauungssystem, Trakt.
Erwarten Sie Herzprobleme?
Ja, natürlich Herz.
Die Patienten haben solche Beschwerden.
Was sollen wir am Anfang tun?
Zünex würde sich an die Körperliche Unterzucht üben und Vitalparameter erheben.
Es ist besonders Blutdruckmessen.
Wie möchten Sie den Blutdruck messen?
Beidseitig oder linksseitig oder rechtsseitig?
Beidseitig.
Ist das wichtig?
Wir haben den Blutdruck gemessen und das ist hoch.
Ist das genug?
Das ist nicht hoch, aber die Patienten haben solche Beschwerden wie Vertigo.
Bei manchen Situationen ist es wichtig, zum Beispiel die Autosektion.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Autosektion?
Was können Sie da erwarten?
Was könnte es sein? Wie können Sie es verstehen?
Wir können diese Diagnose nicht feststellen, aber welche Unterschiede?
Neurologische Befunde erwarten Sie.
Ich meine Autosektion.
Gibt es einen Unterschiede? Blutdruckmessung?
Ja, richtig.
Weil Autosektion gibt es einen Riss, deswegen erwarte ich bei einer Teile einen erniedrigten Blutdruck.
Das ist nicht gleich?
Ja, richtig.
Was ist die Differenz?
Mindestens können wir zum Beispiel rechtsseitig 160 und linksseitig 150.
Ja, ich habe keine weitere Information.
Okay, okay.
Welche Untersuchungen planen Sie?
Für diese Patienten?
Ja, genau.
Zunächst schaue ich mir ihre Körper an, dann würde ich ihre Lunge und Herz und Bauch abtasten.
Dann würde ich ihre Bauch und Herz und Lunge abführen.
Dann würde ich EKG schreiben lassen, um eine kardiologische Ursache auszuschließen.
Lungenaskutation ist das wichtig?
Ja, alle Untersuchungsmethode sind wichtig.
Ja, genau. Aber was erwarten Sie bei Lungenaskutation?
Bei Lungenaskutation erwarte ich...
Zum Beispiel, der Patient hat eine Organeschädigung bei Lunge.
Welche Schädigung könnte es sein?
Was erwarten Sie bei dieser Situation? Ich meine es.
Lungenkontakt?
Lungenödemen?
Ja, bei Lungenödemen erwarte ich eine Femminderung.
Und wir können auch durch Inspektion diese Situation verstehen.
Bei Inspektion erwarte ich Atemhilfemuskulatur.
Oder Cyanose?
Ich weiß nicht, aber der Patient kann schwitzen.
Und Atemgeruch können wir bemerken.
Und wenn der Patient sitzt, können Sie besser einatmen.
Und welche Laborkuntersuchung würden Sie anbieten?
Bei Laborkuntersuchung würde ich Blutbildentzündungsparameter, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte und Ferritin für Anämie.
Aber wir sind in unserer Aufnahme nicht Ferritin.
Der Patient hat Nocturi und er hat auch Durst.
Ja, das richtig bestimmen.
Könnte der Patient auch Diabetes mellitus haben?
Nein, laut Angaben hat er keine Diabetes mellitus.
Aber es könnte sein, weil er Durst und Nocturi hat.
Ja, ich meine wir können auch diese Situation beherrschen.
Blutzucker, Hemozide, Hemofilz.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Wir haben diese Diagnose festgestellt.
Der Patient hat seit fünf Jahren Atemhypertonie.
Aber vielleicht brauchen wir ihre Medikationen umstellen.
Ja, richtig.
Was planen Sie? Oder was empfehlen Sie?
Was planen Sie für die Therapie?
Zunächst würden wir die Patienten für die Ambulanz behandeln.
Wenn der Patient Hypertensiver Notfall hat?
Nein, Intensivstationäre aufnehmen.
Wenn der Patient Hypertensiv-Krise hat?
Ambulanz behandeln.
Ambulanz behandeln, ok.
Wie können wir den Blutdruck senken? Schnell oder langsam?
Langsam natürlich.
Wie langsam?
Ich würde zunächst einen Zugang legen und Flüssigkeit bevor mit Elektrolyte einleiten.
Ja, dann würde ich die Urethika geben.
Kann ich die Urethika geben?
Oder Antihypertensiva geben.
Zum Beispiel Beta Blöcke, Angeoreceptor Blöcke, ACA, MA.
Ok, ich glaube das ist abhängig von den Ergebnissen.
Ja, richtig.
Und ich glaube wir können auch per Oral oder Antihypertensiva Medikamente geben.
Ich glaube das ist wichtig. Wir sollen den Blutdruck langsam senken.
Und ich glaube in der ersten Stunde sollen wir das Maximum 20 bis 25% senken.
In der ersten Stunde das Maximum 20% senken.
Das bedeutet nicht so schnell.
Wenn wir schnell senken, ist das gefährlich?
Natürlich ist das gefährlich. Das kann zu Hinschädigung führen.
Ja, Organeschädigung verursacht das, glaube ich.
Und was empfehlen Sie der Patienten bei diesem Fall?
Ich empfehle ihr, ihre Hausarzt regelmäßig zu besuchen.
Aber sie hat Probleme bei den Hausärzten, glaube ich.
Ok, eine neue Hausarzt aufzusuchen.
Und ihre Medikamente anzupassen.
Und ihr wird zu verlieren, Sport treiben, Diät machen.
Sie ist übergewicht.
Ungefähr 35% hat sie.
35%?
Ich glaube.
Ich denke nicht. 1,87 Meter.
1,60 Meter.
Ah, 1,60 Meter. Entschuldigung, ich habe 80 verstanden.
Im Pack-Up ist es 1,80 Meter oder 1,60 Meter?
80 Meter.
Ok, sie ist nicht übergewicht.
Aber nicht fit.
Aber Gewichtreduktion ist immer wichtig bei der Repertation. Oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Und was noch? Was empfehlen Sie noch?
Lebensgewohnheitenveränderung? Empfehlen Sie?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, fettarmiges Ernährungs-Balanzstoff reicht.
Zunächst?
Zunächst.
Saatsarmig oder?
Ja, weniger Salz zu rundmieren.
Und empfehlen Sie Sport zu treiben?
Ja, ich habe erwähnt Sport treiben, Diät machen.
Ok, Entschuldigung.
Und regelmäßig Medikamente einzunehmen und regelmäßig Blutdruck zu messen.
Sie haben es gesagt.
Ok, vielen Dank für diese gute Vorstellung.
Nehmen Sie bitte Ihr Zertifikat.
Wir haben keine Zertifikat bekommen.
Ja, wir nehmen direkt.
Wir nehmen direkt nach der Prüfung.
Morgen oder Abend. Eine E-Mail.
Aber das ist meine Bitte.
Ok, während der Prüfung wird es gefragt, was ist Entgleisung?
Aber ich weiß nicht, was ist Entgleisung.
Das ist eine generelle Asteroid-Erklaube.
Entgleisung und Entgleisung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das beantworten soll.
Das ist eine Krise.
Die Zertifikat wird entgleist.
Entgleisung und Entgleisung.
Und dann geht es von normalen Grenzen um die Kontrolle der Patienten.
Ich habe diese Patienten schon seit fünf Jahren.
Sie haben sie getroffen.
Aber sie haben keine Medizin.
Sie haben keine Medizin für die ersten zwei Jahre.
Ich habe sie getroffen.
Sie haben keine Medizin.
Sie haben sie getroffen.
Sie haben sich getroffen.
Aber wie K.K.Kemal beinhaltet,
beginnt mit Kopf und beginnt mit Kopf,
bis unten, Vegetative Anamnesis,
nicht alles natürlich,
aber Fiber, Leymung,
Type-S-Gefühl,
direkt unten,
Herzstraßen,
Brust-Engel-Gefühl,
direkt unten,
Übelkeit, Erbrechen
Stolgank,
Wie ist Ihr Stolgank Wasalasen
Hemen aradan bir Wasalasen orada
Söyleyebiliyo,
Yoksa Söylemiyo gerçekten.
Hemen aşağı inip ne sorabiliyoruz ordan,
ne kaldı?
İşte Yemeye içmeyi,
Gewichti, sordun, o güzel bu hasta da...
Hani,
genelde bu hasta,
BME Obviously yüksek geliyo,
amay burada şey geldi.
Ich habe es schon zweimal gesagt, dass ich 3 Liter Wasser trinke.
Du hast es direkt normal gesagt, aber man muss sich fragen, ob es eine Veränderung gibt.
Du trinkst zu wenig.
Das ist ein Gewohnheit.
Das ist der Unterschied von normalen Krankenhäusern.
Da steht die Zeit, ich möchte die Zeit in eine Art trinken.
Du hast das Recht.
Das ist ein Witz.
Wenn ich in diese Gespräche gehe, dann muss ich in ein paar Minuten hierher.
In diese Gespräche muss man aber die Differentiale Anerkennung schreiben.
Das muss man auf Teil 3 sagen.
Die Differentiale Diagnose ist nicht das Ziel.
Es ist ein Argument, das Begründet ist, etwas zu tun.
Das ist ein Ausdruck.
Da man die Zeit nicht genug sieht, kann man die Zeit aus dem Ausdruck sagen.
Ich kann es noch mal sagen, weil ich 17 Erfahrungen habe.
Ich hatte 17 Erfahrungen.
Die ganzen Erfahrungen waren ein Burnout.
Ich habe nicht richtig verstanden, ob das eine Exzellent-Krisen-Krise sein würde.
Im letzten Jahr war die Krise nicht mehr vorhanden.
Ich hatte die Chance, dass ich in den Test-Krisen war.
Aber es ist noch ein paar Tage später.
Das ist interessant.
Es ist noch ein paar Tage später.
Aber es ist ein Burnout.
Ich habe eine gute Idee für die Begründung des Anerkennungs.
Fellus ist der Kontrollierter.
Ich bin der Unkontrollierter.
Unkontrollierter ist nicht gut angekündigt.
Ja.
Ja, es kommt jetzt ein Burnout.
Die Tension für den Burnout muss normal sein.
Erzähl das nicht.
Ich mische jeden Tag.
Ich habe sogar das Geschenk für den Burnout gemerkt.
Ich habe es gerade gesagt.
Aber wie richtig ist es, normal zu sein?
Mein Anerkennungs-Kolleitler sagt, dass es nur eine Größe im Monat reicht.
Aber was warten die Anerkennungs-Kolleitler?
Trotzdem muss man den Anerkennungs-Kranz für den Burnout-Kranz schreiben.
Das kann auch für den Anker sein.
Das ist das, was ich mit Oberarzt sagen kann.
Oberarzt sagt, dass der Anker das richtig sagt.
Nein, das ist nicht der Anker.
Der Anker hat nur eine Frage.
Ist es nicht für den Frühen?
Vielleicht versucht er das zu messen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, das war die ganze Sache.
Mein Anerkennungs-Kolleitler sagt, dass es 600 Reset-Flict ist.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Ich benutze die von meinem Anerkennungs-Kolleitler.
Ja, das ist 400.
Das ist das, was ich mit Oberarzt sagen kann.
Aber das ist das, was ich mit Oberarzt sagen kann.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist das, was ich mit Oberarzt sagen kann.
Okay.
Mein Anerkennungs-Kolleitler sagt, dass er das nicht mag.
Das ist die ganze Sache.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Tü, Sefalci.
Was?
Sefalci aber.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Es ist wie...
Es ist nicht nur Sefalci.
Es gibt eine Jury.
Sie sagen alles.
Sie sagen auch Nauzien.
Was der Patient dir gesagt hat, sag es mir.
Es gab in der Türkei auch so einen Doktor.
Sie sagten uns die Patientendien.
Weil du dich selbst
als Sefalci bezeichnet hast.
Sie sagten uns die Patientendien,
aber nicht wie du.
Ich kann das nicht machen.
Ich sag mal.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich sag Sefalci.
Aber es tut mir leid.
Er tut mir leid.
Obwohl.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Ich kann es sagen.
Wir haben eine Stimmung.
Ich habe es nicht gesagt, dass ich es in der Tat benutze.
In der Tat ist es schon unsere Zeitung.
Und jetzt, Herr Professor, wir haben auch eine Relevante in der Tests.
Wir haben das nicht vergessen.
Okay.
Inşallah.
Aber natürlich ist eine Medikamenten oder ein V4R-Krankung wichtig.
Aber ist die Hühner-Aufgabe wichtig?
Nein.
Zum Beispiel.
Ich habe es nicht gesagt, dass ich es in der Tat benutze.
Herr Professor, der Professor Ibrahim hat auch die Stimme gehalten.
Das war genau seine Fall.
Er sollte sich vorbereiten.
Wenn das Volk in der Tat besser wird,
werden wir die hypertensiven Krisen, die wir von ihm hören,
mit der Gnade erarbeiten.
Ja, ich habe das auch gedacht.
Ich wünsche Ihnen auch viel Erfolg.
Inşallah wird es in einer ordentlichen und einfachen Art und Weise werden.
Insofern wird es eine leichte Jury werden.
Ich bin die zweite.
Ein Appendiset kann mit einer schwierigen Kommission ein Problem passieren.
Inşallah werden Sie Ihre Fehler mit der Spire sagen.
Ja.
Major Fehler mit Minoren sehen.
Minoren werden mit der Spire verantworten.
Das ist ein sehr einfaches Problem.
Insofern wird es ein Problem sein.
Das ist möglich.
Das ist überall möglich.
Die erste Regel in Deutschland ist,
dass Ihr Ereignis immer auf der Stelle befindet,
auf der Stelle der Person, mit der Ihr Kontakt ist.
Das ist normal.
Das ist überall möglich.
Das fühlt sich in Deutschland wohl noch ein bisschen.
Amen.
Okay, Herr Professor.
Ich werde jetzt den Abendessen machen.
Du kannst mit mir und mir mit der Tie2-Sitzung auswählen.
Ja, wir können mit Tie2 und Tie3 auswählen.
Du kannst mit mir mit der Tie2-Sitzung auswählen.
Okay.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Insofern wird es ein Erfolg, Herr Professor.
Wir werden uns morgen auf einen Ejdel anbieten.
Auf Wiedersehen.